yeah I saw on Instagram you said that
you had been on probation you got off in
2020 but you were on probation since you
were 12 years old yeah because you know
when you were a Jew now you go to jail
for anything you'd be out out the curfew
you go to jail violation so like every
time you go to jail it start your [ __ ]
over so I never got my [ __ ] right until
I got so the whole time just every time
you get hit for some random [ __ ] they
would just be like reset anything you
know and then I'll get a gun case you
know should that make sense right I get
a gun case back then weed charges it's a
little certain [ __ ] like that and it'll
just keeps starting over starting over I
think the last time I went to the county
was like
two thousand 2014 probably 15 or 14.
because how long was were you originally
supposed to be on papers I think the
first time when I was 12 was like
three years or five years what did you
do at 12 to get you on that again oh at
12 years old I was in the stolen core
were you driving the strolling car at 12
I even know how to drive I stole it but
I ain't I wasn't driving I didn't know
how to drive at the time he had an
interesting uh sixth grade year huh yeah
that was crazy yeah I lost my virginity
at night
Howard was the girl she was 15. okay I
lied I thought I was 13.
so you lost your virginity at nine years
old you get arrested for stealing a car
and having a gun on you at 12.
my goodness man
do you do you have do you still like see
the girl you lost your virginity to
online ever yeah I've seen it on there
how she look now
she doesn't look like uh my type of girl
yeah it's funny because like I'll see
like when I was like 11 or 12 like
people had crushes on when I was a kid
and then like they pop up on Facebook
and I'm like [ __ ] if I see anybody had a
crush on unless they lost it
they still like they still good they
still look good not me man these [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] with in Arizona
30 kids it's only got some bad [ __ ]
of course not just me when I was like a
little kid man there was always like a
like my I had like family friends like
my my dad's uh Boss's Daughter I used to
like and like now she's just like she's
ran it's bad and when you're a kid
though you only you like what you
accessible to facts you don't know
nothing about all these other people you
know your daughters I mean your friends
daughter your dad's friend's daughter
right that's all you know so you don't
know what looks better than that right
you know this is a girl so when you're
[ __ ] at nine how long you last bro it
didn't last long because uh my brother
walked in I don't say you're are you
like did you you did you finish no I
didn't I didn't she kept saying don't
come don't come I am I even know what
kind of weather at the time I'm like
[ __ ]
did she have to like kind of show you
what to do no no you knew I was watching
pornos and [ __ ] Jesus Christ it's just
nine just [ __ ] you were watching VHS
tapes
for sure DVDs yeah Booty Talk Booty Talk
number 78 starring [ __ ] Pinky or
[ __ ] uh pinky pinky was after yeah
I'm about to say pinky was definitely
after back then I don't even know that's
like you know who was the uh what was
the girl's name uh the OG uh Heather
Hunter do you remember her
she was like I sound familiar but uh I
would I don't know the names like that I
know pinky for sure but yeah pinkies I
don't know she's also a [ __ ] yeah I
think she's a daughter before she is so
short yeah she's a dwarf
she's somebody who the years haven't
been great to either I just saw her
recently oh Jesus Christ uh uh so you
you [ __ ] at nine you don't finish your
friend is your friend or your cousin
interrupts who interrupted my brother
your brother interrupted you want to set
it up did he come in and finish the job
no no she was she was done uh
it's funny though because uh he he was
in Middle School I was in elementary but
I didn't go to school I was at my dad's
house for the day he told me to come
walk up to a school pick him up because
it was down the street yeah I wanted to
pick him up and he's like all the girls
gonna like you so when they said oh he's
so cute this is your brother and I'm
like yeah they're like how old is you my
mom 13. I go to Einstein's to school
that I end up going to right but I knew
but you weren't in there yet yeah yeah
so I go to Einstein I'm 13.
I was like oh he's so cute [ __ ] Summer's
come the summer come that one of the
girls come over every day we play truth
dare ah yeah so started off touching
start off each day got more crazier and
the last there was [ __ ] last day my
brother she went to the bathroom my
brother like if I did you want me to
dare to [ __ ] you I'm like yeah and at
the time he had version too he's six
years older than me right everything he
my dad never let him leave the house
without me so everything he learned for
the first time and did for the first
time I did right so he like I'm uh I'm
gonna dare to [ __ ] my heart she came
back and he's like if I dare you to [ __ ]
myself uh will you and she like yeah
she's like all right shoot she had to
been around the block a little huh she
probably was she was like yeah no
problem give me the nine-year-old she
didn't know I was nine though did she
ever find out now let me tell you though
it's crazy and then uh she won't know
now she never found out but uh after
that my brother walked in for like not
even long like 10 seconds down there
like not long but you got in there I got
in there there's a few pumps yeah bam my
brother walking all right I'm done
uh she put her [ __ ] on it and he he
trying to do his [ __ ] she's like nah I
like your brother he told me to go he
told me to go get uh
but one of our friends that live around
the corner and I uh has he just was over
here his mom just picked him up he was
he said he was grounded right so I know
he's bullshitting so and I'm like
grounded he's like no I said he said
come get him so I go outside act like I
leave come in and sit by the door I'm
listening he's like you know you just
[ __ ] a nine-year-old right
I'm like oh this [ __ ] ah so I walk out
I mean I open the door I sit for a
minute
go out
act like you're coming in I come in and
[ __ ] and she's like yeah I'm gonna go
home all right she's like you trying to
walk me home oh yeah I walk around she
like your brother said you're nice you
know I might not he's just mad cause you
won't let him and she's like oh yeah I
thought that's what it was wow
now she gonna know now she knows that
your brother was telling the truth yeah
for sure
Okay so
you're obviously a badass kid for sure
that was bad for sure for sure